tais versos lâmpada 32 vai colaborar
final do júri em dietas falam em dia
tudo junto
vou testar o integrismo lançar maria
pacote não pára quedismo glória maria
para a outra estava em saber as
respostas do smn não fala do lado suave
o que falar andar que tudo muito bem
vindos dele a lembrança que o vídeo que
eu fiz com 10 anos a lei funciona porque
a cobra é cobra escutei ele culpou
alguns dos vossos comentários com muita
gente pediu para eu tentar eletrocutado
e elektro para uma lâmpada como precisar
de uma lâmpada supostamente funciona com
eletricidade uma tenda funciona com
eletricidade ou descarga desfilar mas
pra que tudo tem muito poderoso para
acender uma lâmpada não paciência no
hemistério inter eu adorei a idéia
portanto nós vamos tentar fazer isso
acender uma lâmpada conta eu não vou
tentar acender o única lâmpada não não
vou mais além
então eu comprei o um saco cheio de lama
ainda tem outro atrás pedra rolou e
estou mandando em grande eu comprei
muitas longo dos mesmos vários tipos de
coisas diferentes e dá tudo igualzinho a
lei não vai acontecer a lâmpada vai
receber o assunto não vai ser só agora
tem para que atingir uma meta de bem
mais nesse vídeo para continuar a ter
vários países tanto como eu tenho é que
vocês querem ver desde o galaxy em dia e
é melhor
olha só é bem linda por dentro e agora
nós vamos fazer é um simples muito
simples é só executar esta parte aqui
embaixo de ver o que acontece
será que ela ainda vai marcar e espero
que junto com sua mãe que eu ia dizer só
primeiro lugar sempre segurança portanto
vamos usar nossos busquets lembra dessas
duas nexon faca 500 maçarico a princesa
intitulada só vamos fazer então por
manter se eu vou ganhar aqui na minha
lâmpada que acontece em choque elétrico
nela mora lá e serviços lâmpada 323 211
o texto só entrará amanhã dentro e 321
vai ainda que esta é uma lâmpada mais
futurista é uma lâmpada led tem uma
substância amarela e lá então poder
pessoal nossa vida contra a lâmpada
funcionar melhor e não funciona
32 vai ficar tudo escuro organismo
incrível 321 vai
[Música]
mesmo assim os quatro pneus do carro à
conclusão que esta que funciona muito
melhor de lâmpada led mas o que acontece
se o eléctrico para o vidro será que
parte será que uma parte envolvida até
agora acreditava se explique um pouco
embora lá 321 bairro é muito comum por
dentro tem muitas vezes e dentro de um
pão branco bem estranho mas será que se
pode fazer um estrago hipótese de saltar
bem estamos vendo agora eu acho que sou
eu mesmo ok go carlos ou três meses
atrás a r 32
vai funcionar assim também eu acho
clique na lata eram os reflexos desta
luz ou seja a própria luz no país estava
convencida que no branco só não comprei
essa mancada mais pequena aliás vem com
três vans são três lagoas bem pequenas e
hoje em santos porque ela já tem dois
filhos fora
eu posso não estar diretamente nestes
dois pinos e com uma lâmpada pequena e
ela só aguenta pouca voltagem dental
estuda é não sair mas não vê 321 321 vai
vai ficar muito vermelho wall incrível
sua partida muito queimado sério tira
mesmo tal quem tá mesmo quinto vidro só
até agora essa foi a que melhor atendeu
eo trânsito estava certo quanto mais
porque nem lembrei quanto menor é
resistente mais fácil é defender a bola
sua próxima lâmpada
ok eu tenho que estar muito muito boas e
porque com preços dos lombos porque é
que estão muito possíveis estas pequenas
mas um pouco maior e também têm estes
dois pinos brutal o que quer dizer que
só vai entrar lá muito bem porque já tem
o aval positivo e negativo é ali dentro
de uma pequena resistência caiu também o
texto agora aqui conosco e os abaixo
busca para vocês verem ok vou estar aqui
321 vai meu vibra muito vibra muito
amplas e vibra muito e desta vez não
sentir só constituem uma vibração muito
forte não anda ok vou tentar outra vez
não posso ficar quente não ficar com
laranja não está fazendo nada eu só tô
sem vibração é a única coisa que sinto
só vamos parar aqui olha só 321 vai
eu só faço política pode ser que se
esteja estragada vou experimentar esta
está muito úmida cara que dá muito
diversão que só isso não funciona - as
primeiras duas lâmpadas nada bora lá
então sua próxima lâmpada agora estamos
aqui eu acho que não vou fazer nada com
ela porque ela é muito parecida à outra
branca só comprei porque esta em caracol
e então como não há outra lesionada por
que um pó branco e não faltou só que é
provável que não aconteça eu também vou
usar uma lâmpada esta vai ser muito
importante mesmo
vejam só essas bandas são muito finas e
compridas e lá dentro tem uma
resistência gigante o que quer dizer que
ela pode ficar cor laranja o que quer
viver que é seu e consequentemente ela
pode publicar isso que eu quero falar
bem
eu acho que isso aqui é bem complicado
porque em cada conta tem um pólo tem o
positivo eo negativo agora vou tentar só
então assim de ponta e vamos ver o que
acontece
321 vai condicionar ainda é isso que
está acontecendo que estava a pensar o
que eu posso fazer é juntar um pouco o
papel de alumínio em ambas as pontas e
depois reunir o papel de alumínio com
thaísa e assim o tesouro vai conseguir
mandar eletricidade para ambos os povos
e por que ela é mais ou menos assim
agora as duas pontas e vamos ver o que
acontece
321 vai agora é destaque por isso mesmo
porque ela é muito grande em relação ao
preço 21 ae
[Música]
igual a si mesmo jeito que eu queria do
juro no centro não entendeu as idéias de
mel ela só 321 vai rolar estendeu de uma
governo é possível
[Música]
lembro muito tempo eu não sou de ficar
com os filhos para fazer um estádio que
já sabem pessoal desde o vosso magali
que você tava termos similares neste
vídeo e comentei coisas que tenham que
eu faça a conta ainda é muito importante
pessoal aqui em cima vocês vão conseguir
ver os dois filhos entre os que aqui
embaixo vocês podem se inscrever aqui no
canal dos frangos 10 pessoal fica em
baia de aproximar